c'est peut-être une des seule fois dans
notre vie où on ce qu'on se passera en
mode drive et voilà donc le l'église
sait s'adapter à cette situation pour
permettre aux fidèles d'avoir accès à ce
sacrement et ça c'est génial avec la
pandémie
le drive s'est largement démocratisée
smm réinventer pour ce faire confesser
comme ici à limoges ou dans un autre
style pour voir des strip-teases comme
ici aux etats unis des pratiques
inédites pourtant le drive est entré
dans notre quotidien depuis bien
longtemps dans les années 60 ce n'est
encore qu'un rêve rester dans sa voiture
pour faire ses courses
il faudra attendre les années 80 pour
que le drive devienne réalité en france
et c'est tout d'abord avec les
fast-foods 1985 au quick de
saint-etienne c'est les etats-unis mais
sans l'accent dès l'ouverture les
amateurs de hamburgers était conquis le
drive voyez passer 500 voitures par jour
rapidité c'est le maître mot il ne
s'écoule que 45 secondes entre la
commande et la remise du repas c'était
ça l'argument phare car à l'époque la
distanciation social n'était pas un
problème
il fallait être rapide et pratique comme
ce drive pour déposer ses impôts sans
sortir de sa voiture
j'apprécie donc pas c'est rivière ne
s'aiment pas ça fait gagner du temps la
plomberie ou un drive pour le pain
quotidien ou encore le drive pour la
pharmacie il existe depuis peu à colmar
la pharmacie au volant plus besoin de se
garer on peut se procurer des
médicaments en restant derrière son
volant
ces initiatives restent locales mais à
partir des années 2000 les super marchés
tests eux aussi le drive à plus grande
échelle
faire ses courses sans descendre de sa
voiture l'expérience a été tentée depuis
ce matin dans la région de lille et
c'est tout de suite un succès ça a
changé vraiment quelque chose pour vous
bah ouais on maintenant on passe le plus
de temps en famille et puis on attend
plus on patiente plus en caisse
c'est tranquille en mai 2019
il y avait 5000 113 drive d'hypermarchés
en france en europe
l'hexagone est d'ailleurs le pays qui a
le plus recours au drive pour les
courses alimentaires
une pratique qui va sûrement encore plus
se développer dans la france de l'après
confinement
[Musique]